pères il était une fois dans le sud
ouest
si futile excité 1 en tant qu rentrant
beloeil à ta mère ivoiriens feignant
d'artagnan monteur
pendant ce temps dans la cour du louvre
sauf le mardi c'est fermé trois joyeux
compagnons devisent gaiement porthos
athos salut lévis et 3 bastille ce nom
et 3 passes tes d'artagnan qui veut
réussir dans la vie aussi bien que son
vote racinien cash qui décide de rentrer
dans les crs
entendez par là les compagnies royal de
sécurité au port tous et toutes choses
tous les matches est ce que je peux
faire partie de la bande
mais l'otage a crevé lui est amer
françois me prodware travers ce petit
corps
bon ben je veux leur donner un coup de
main parce qu'on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge
un cardinal jeu c'est bientôt fini ce
bordel là c'est rien cardinal une petite
gare un sympathique gavage voilà pendant
ce temps dans les appartements de la
reine anne d'autriche qui fournissait en
plumes tous les chapeaux des
mousquetaires à mon roi je suis content
tu te fous fois heureusement qu'on
n'habite pas bourg la reine
ça ferait jaser aux appliques chilly
mazarin
et mon petit cadeau qu'est ce que c'est
différent
ah j'adore léo ferré pikine cave vous
pouvez sortir de l'armoire
je vous offre ces ferrer une choucroute
et un p tit coup avant de partir au long
merci mardi à metz doit rentrer quand je
prends de ratu la marée car à l'époque
il n'y avait pas d'avion
la choucroute la bière importée coucher
l'amour je l'étais akli débrouillards
d'artagnan à trouver un logement
et on est bien le bon à quoi laisser
tranquille les mecs je ride vidéo mon
chéri pour je te parle
ma patronne laine d'autruche et baleines
à rosbif alors toujours est-il qu'elle
lui a refilé cydia mais leur faut que tu
fais tes potes il allait chercher en
angleterre
michel taubmann les matches aller on se
marre en angleterre et moi ni mon va
rater le marais car à l'époque il n'y
avait pas d'avion
les mousquetaires pense la manche c'est
fini oui arrivé à londres il l'âge à
buckingham palace
mesdames et messieurs bruce la baignoire
de lady di il se précipite sur le liban
fc bonne mais oui il fait et il saute
sur les dix lits à éviter d'être moche
il sentait mieux prédire ce qui se passe
mais j'entends le bruit natural jacques
garçon il via leur hystérie référé bravo
les mecs manier rouge et les cayes
pendant qu'un aux héroïnes 0 chevaux ce
jeu veauche sur leurs chevaux cheminant
sur le chemin au louvre sauf le mardi
c'est fermé le bal va commence mais le
plus gros choc des titans les salons
feutrés du loup vous ça va juste eh oui
le logiciel va ouvrir le bal
le bal est ouvert à l'eau non elle est
toujours maintenant il est très rare
allez allez terminaux ici
la n 11 d'artagnan n'est toujours pas
arrivé m habile pas marraine
il est toujours à l'heure l'objet aucun
jeu il y va donc chercher une boîte
d'allumettes balle est revenue sans la
boîte d'allumettes mais les revues quant
à leur marraine j'ai les séries il a
reconnu qu'on loges alors à dix
compagnons toujours là et un
pousse-pousse douloureux et un pouce
pouce alors nous pourrions y est